Did you know that this guy who can turn
into a chicken has an even higher bounty
than Franky? Or that many bounties
contain hidden messages in Japanese?
Or that poor Chopper, who’s always mistaken
for the pet of the Straw Hats actually isn’t
the character with the smallest bounty in
One Piece? Instead, that really sad title
actually goes to Bepo, the orange jumpsuit
wearing polar bear from Trafalgar Law’s
crew. With only 500 berries, Bepo has a smaller
bounty than any other character in One Piece,
which is kind of crazy considering Bepo’s fierce
Sulong transformation in the manga. However,
it seems that since Bepo is a mink,
the World Government thinks he’s
just…an actual polar bear instead of
the navigator of the Heart Pirates.
And the case is very similar for the
second highest bounty: Tony-Tony Chopper,
who the government thinks is just the Straw
Hats’ pet. However, after the Raid on Onigashima,
his bounty was raised to 1,000 berries: twice
the amount of Bepo’s bounty. If the government
knew the truth about Chopper and that he was
one of the smartest members of the crew…and
definitely smarter than his own captain…I’m
sure his bounty would be much, much higher.
Now, it might be a little hard for some
listeners to imagine just how much 1,000
berries is. Since berries are worth approximately
the same as Japanese Yen, the means that turning
in Chopper would earn you around 6.36 Euro
or 6.91 US dollars. So like…not very much.
Now, let’s make the massive leap from
1,000 to 3,200,000 berries. We’re clearly
not in joke bounty territory anymore. This
bounty belongs to Mr. 4 of Baroque Works,
who you might remember as the guy who shattered
all of Usopp’s bones with a baseball bat.
Just above him is this guy at 3,400,000. His name
is Porchemy and we met him in Luffy’s childhood
flashback. This guy worked for the pirate
Bluejam, and his bounty was fittingly low
for someone who lost a fight to two children:
Ace and Sabo. But what can I say, that’s what
you sign up for when you pick on kid Luffy (and
by pick on I mean violently torture kid Luffy).
At a respectable 5,000,000 is the first pirate
we ever saw Luffy beat up in the series:
Iron-Mace Alvida. It’s kind of wild
though that this is the last confirmed
bounty we have for her, though -
one can only speculate that it’s
higher now that she’s technically on
a yonkou crew, working under Buggy.
Poor Chew: it must be sad to have the
lowest bounty on the Arlong Pirates,
separated here from all your crew mates
with only a 5,500,000 berry bounty. Who
knows what your fellow fishmen did
to get a higher bounty than you?
Above him at 7,000,000, there’s a really
unique occurrence: This bounty belongs to the
Nyaban brothers, Sham and Buchi who worked for
Captain Kuro, the main antagonist of the Syrup
Village arc where the crew recruited Usopp..
Like…they share it. And as far as I can see
these brothers are the only characters in all of
One Piece where two different characters share a
single bounty between them. For all you bounty
hunters out there, it’s a two for one deal.
After them, it’s right back over to Baroque Works
with Miss Valentine who boasts
a bounty of 7,500,000 berries.
Above Miss Valentine is Luffy’s caretaker
/ the closest thing he has to a mother,
Curly Dadan. This mountain
bandit who raised Luffy and
Ace after Garp dropped them off in the
Goa Kingdom has a bounty of 7,800,000.
And shockingly, with a bounty above everyone
we’ve seen so far, is the very first bounty
we saw in the whole series: And it’s
another mountain bandit just like Dadan,
but without her heart of gold. That’s
right, it’s Higuma, AKA the guy that
Shanks absolutely wrecked in chapter one
of One Piece with a bounty of 8,000,000.
Exactly tied with that mountain bandit is
the second best swordsman in Fishman Island:
Hatchan. He earned his bounty as part of
the Arlong Pirates, but I wonder if the
marines would still honor that deal now that
Hatchan is just a humble takoyaki salesman.
However, I’m pretty sure the next bounty
has been erased because it belongs to Jango
the Hypnotist. He had a 9,000,000 berry bounty
when he was working for the Black Cat Pirates,
but now that he’s switched sides and joined
the marines, he’s officially bounty free.
But still at 9,000,000 berries as
far as we know is another Arlong
Pirate - Kuroobi aka the guy with
the pig tails that Sanji fought.
At 10,000,000 we have two more pirates.
This random guy who attacked a childhood
Trafalgar Law during his flashback and Baroque
Works’ Mr. 5 - aka explosive Lenny Kravitz.
With 11,000,000 berries, we have the heaviest
member of the Donquixote Family
and the one with the lowest bounty
And with an inexplicably higher bounty
than a member of Doflamingo’s Crew…is Gin,
Don Krieg’s subordinate from the
Baratie arc at 12,000,000 berries.
Jumping up another 2 million for 14 million is yet
another Baroque Works member: the
mole woman, Miss Merry Christmas.
And with a strange number, 14,300,000 berries,
we have Bluejam from Luffy’s childhood flashback.
At 15 mil, we have this little half- fighting
fishman freak, also from the Donquixote Family.
At 16 million berries, we
have Captain Kuro himself,
the pirate who wreaked havoc on
Usopp’s home of Syrup Village.
With 17 million, though, we have the main
villain from the Baratie Arc: Don Krieg.
And for that same bounty, is this random guy
who was on sale at the Sabaody Auction House.
For 20 million, though, we have the highest
bounty in all of the East Blue (besides Luffy,
of course): Arlong. As a former member of
the Sun Pirates who was causing terror in
Cocoyashi Village, no pirate was
more dangerous in the weakest sea.
His bounty likely would have been much
higher if he hadn’t been keeping a
relatively low profile in the East Blue
and regularly paying off the marines.
Another infamous pirate with a bounty
of at least 20 million is Jesus Burgess,
the Captain of Blackbeard’s First
Ship. Now, since Blackbeard has
become a full-fledged Yonkou, I imagine
Burgess’s bounty is much, much higher now,
but 20 million is the last confirmed
bounty we actually have for this character.
And two characters who also have the
20 million berry bounty amount are the
two Yeti Cool Brothers from Punk
Hazard being worth 20 mil each.
Our next character is this monkey man who loves to
salvage from the Jaya Arc with 23 million berries.
Three characters share a bounty of 24 million
and they’re three of the most random characters
you could possibly think of: The wax man,
Mr. 3, Big Mom’s daughter Charlotte Lola,
and one of One Piece’s silliest
villains: Foxy the Silver Fox.
Above all of them, though, with 25 million
is….Montblanc Cricket, the descendant of
Noland the Liar. Who I guess earned this bounty
through the terrible crime of…deep sea diving?
The Captain of the Fake Strawhats from the Return
to Sabaody Archipelago arc has a bounty
of 26 million, which is just sad. This
Fake Strawhat couldn’t even earn the
amount of Luffy’s very first bounty.
Another Baroque Works agent, Miss Golden Week,
AKA the painter girl who worked with Mr.
3 had a bounty of 29 million berries.
For reference, right above that is
Luffy’s first bounty in the East Blue:
30,000,000. Just think for a second:
Luffy’s bounty was higher than every
character we’ve heard so far before
he even entered the Grand Line!
And at 31 million is the most
explosive member of Doffy’s crew
At 32 mil is the pinnacle of
friendship: Mr. 2 Bon Kurei.
His former spiky ally Miss Double Finger,
however had a bounty of 35 million berries.
A few characters share a bounty of 36 million.
First is Shoujou, the other
salvaging gorilla for Jaya.
Here at this price we also have the
coliseum fighter Bobby Funk as well
as this random guy who got beat up by
the Galley-La shipwrights in Water 7.
At 38 mil is this fashionable friend of Bellamy’s
who Doflamingo puppeteered
into a fight with his bestie
Worth 40 million berries each are
the Boa Hancock’s two sisters,
Sandersonia and Marigold of Amazon Lily.
But, obviously worth more than the
two sisters of the pirate empress,
at 42 million…is this random guy from Jaya
With a price of at least 42 million,
though, there’s the Demon Sheriff,
Lafitte. Just like Jesus Burgess, we can guess
that this high-ranking member of Blackbeard’s
crew has also seen a big price hike since
he became the subordinate of a Yonkou,
but 42 mil is the last update we’ve
seen to his bounty in the story.
For example, he’s gotta be higher than this
52 million berry bounty that belongs to the
random Blackbeard allied captain who
attacked the Lulusia Kingdom and got
stomped by the four Revolutionary Army commanders.
At 57 mil is the smaller and angrier
of the two Funk Brothers, Kelly,
and owner of possibly the weirdest devil fruit
in the entire series, the Jacket-Jacket Fruit:
But not to be outdone, at 58 million,
is the most hard-boiled member of
the Donquixote Pirates: Senor Pink.
This pirate whom we met as a slave when
we were first introduced to the Celestial
Dragons on Sabaody Archipelago
is worth 60 million berries
And at 61 mil is the oldest member
of the Doflamingo Family: Lao G.
Van Auger, the sniper of the Blackbeard
Pirates, is another Yonkou Commander
that we can only assume has received
a major bounty increase. But for now,
his last confirmed bounty is
at least 64 million berries.
These two lower ranking members of the Straw Hat
Grand Fleet both share a 67 million berry bounty.
And now we’re definitely
starting to see a pattern here,
but Doc Q also probably has
a higher bounty now. However,
for now this Death God of the Blackbeard
Pirates has a bounty of…at least 72 million.
This crab hand guy who got wrecked by the
New Fishman Pirates was worth 73 million.
Crocodile’s 2nd in command, Daz Bones is worth 75
million for his time in the criminal organization
Baroque Works and might be worth even more now
that he’s a high ranking member of the Cross
Guild. Let’s take a minute to compare that
to some other currencies: 75 million yen,
for my Western viewers, is about 518, 000
US dollars or 476, 000 Euro, so turning
Daz Bones into the government could give you
enough to buy a pretty nice house in cash.
Robin’s mom, Nico Olvia is
worth 79 million - as we know,
anybody familiar with aspects of the Void
Century and the Poneglyphs is definitely
wanted by the government.. Now we’re
starting to get up there, but trust me,
we’ve barely scratched the surface on the
unbelievably high bounties in One Piece.
Brownbeard, objectively the worst of all
the characters who are a color and a beard,
is worth the very peculiar bounty amount of
80,060,000. Why did the government tack
on that 60,000? The world may never know.
This random rookie who joined up with
the Fake Straw Hats was worth 88 mil
And Gotti, Capone Bege’s crew mate and man
with a machine gun for an arm, is worth 90.
And at 92, we have this *other*
rookie who joined the Fake Straw
Hats and is doing his best mummy impression
Rockstar, one of Shanks’ subordinates in
the Red Hair Pirates is worth 94 million
And owner of one of the longest
tongues in all of One Piece,
Vito of the Firetank Pirates,
has a bounty of 95 million.
However, now it’s finally time for some crewmates
to share an equal bounty amount. After all,
sharing is caring. And sharing the bounty of
99 million each are the three top executives
of the Donquixote Family: Diamante, Pica,
and Trebol. These three powerhouses are
the centerpiece of Doflamingo’s hold over
Dressrosa, running much of the political
machinery of the island. These three were even
responsible for taking in a young Doflamingo
and warping him into the maniacal evil he
is today. Now that’s what I call parenting!
And finally, we reach the benchmark of 100
million berries: a bounty shared by the two
captains of the Giant Warrior Pirates: Dorry
and Brogy. Who knows how high their bounty
would be if they had been pirating for
the past century instead of dueling each
other on Little Garden? Now that they’re
hanging out with their best bud Shanks,
though, maybe they’ll finally get a giant
sized bounty to match their…giant size.
Also with 100 million was Straw Hat
Luffy after he defeated Sir Crocodile
in Alabasta. After defeating a warlord, the
government really started to take him more
seriously as a threat. But that would
be nothing compared to his next bounty.
Level 5 of Impel Down only houses prisoners with
bounties over 100 million. So while we don’t know
their exact bounty numbers, these three characters
have at least that: there’s this guy who joined
up with Buggy after the prison break as well as
the Revolutionaries Emporio Ivankov and Inazuma,
who were housed in Level 5 before moving
to the secret Level 5.: Newkama Land.
Now the bounties are getting so high
we’re getting into Yonkou subordinate
territory. With 105,500,000 is one
of the first Big Mom crew members
the audience met and one of them who had
the least impact on the story: Bobbin.
Now that we’ve crossed the 100 mil threshold,
we also get to highlight Supernovas, starting
with the one we’ve seen least in the story: Mad
Monk Urouge who has a 108,000,000 berry bounty.
Charlotte Mont D’Or, another Big Mom subordinate
and wielder of the book devil fruit, 120 million.
Orlumbus, one of the commanders of the Straw Hat
grand fleet who brought his 4,300 men under Luffy,
has a bounty of 148 million. In
USD, that would be around 1,022,000,
so turning in Orlumbus would make you an
American millionaire. Sadly for Europe,
though, it’s just shy at around 940,000 Euro.
But that’s nothing compared to this pirate
with a staggering 190 million…it’s…Coribou? No,
not Caribou - his brother. This just
goes to show that bounties don’t always
correspond to strength. Coribou didn’t
earn his high bounty from his power,
but from he and his brother’s
love of killing marines.
Bouncing into the next spot with 195 is
Bellamy, the owner of the Spring-Spring fruit.
Sharing a bounty of 200 million are the
ultimate Straw Hat super fan Bartolomeo
and the supernova that just can’t stop laughing,
Killer. And just for frame of reference,
that makes these two worth 10 Arlongs each!
Three random characters also happen
to have a bounty of 210 million that
are in no way related to each other. We have
Caribou, famous for being Coribou’s brother;
Squard, the Judas of the Whitebeard allies;
and Don Sai, another commander of the Straw
Hat Grand Fleet and known Charlos hitter.
X-Drake, another Supernova
and secret member of SWORD,
has a bounty of 222,000,000. Since
he’s secretly working for the marines,
who knows how legit that bounty is. But since
we know SWORD members have technically resigned
from the marines, we bet you could make a
pretty penny by bringing in this allosaurus.
At 230,000,000 is Fisher Tiger: After Fisher Tiger
scaled the Red Line with his bare hands and freed
the slaves from Mariejois, we’re surprised his
bounty doesn’t the billion mark - but once we
get to that point, you’ll see just how crazy
some of the pirates who have that amount are.
Page One comes in at 290. As one of the members of
the Flying Six, he’s one of Kaidou’s top
subordinates and has a bounty to match.
A little bit higher at 293 million is Morley of
the Revolutionary Army - obviously a Revolutionary
deserves a big bounty, but she also has the
distinction of being one of the few people
to ever break out of Impel Down…well,
before the massive breakout, of course.
Bartholomew Kuma, the king turned revolutionary
turned warlord turned cyborg turned slave,
has a bounty of 296 million.
Three characters share a bounty of 300
million: The first is Caesar Clown,
whose evil scientist exploits and many weapons
of mass destruction soundly earn him that high
bounty. The next two, though, are two brothers
who Caesar would absolutely not like to run into,
lest he be imprisoned by Big Mom again. That
would be Charlotte Oven and Charlotte Daifuku,
the triplet brothers of Katakuri, and two of Big
Mom’s strongest non Sweet-Commander children.
However, those aren’t the only
characters who’ve had a 300 million
berry bounty - this was also Luffy’s
bounty after the Straw Hats’ all out
assault on Enies Lobby where they officially
declared war against the world government.
Lindbergh, another Revolutionary
Army commander has earned a bounty
of 316 million for his rebellious
actions against the World Government.
Three characters also share the bounty amount
of 320 million. The first two are members of the
Worst Generation: First, Basil Hawkins, who served
under Kaidou as one of his headliners (and judging
by those marks on his forehead…the most literal
headliner). Second, we have Jewelry Bonney,
the daughter of Bartholomew Kuma. We’re
sure that whatever part of Kuma is still
conscious is very proud of his daughter for
achieving a higher bounty than her old man.
The third pirate with a 320 million
berry bounty is a former Shichibukai,
Gekko Moriah. Turns out stealing and
reanimating corpses is a severe crime. Who knew?
The 330 million berry bounty also goes to two
different pirates, the first being Pekoms,
the mink subordinate of Big Mom and
the second being another commander
of the Straw Hat Grand Fleet:
Cavendish of the Beautiful Pirates.
Donquixote Doflamingo feels surprisingly low on
the list considering how many more characters
with higher bounties we have left. Of course,
we have to factor in that his bounty of 340
million was frozen when he was granted Warlord
status. Had his bounty been able to increase,
I’m sure his position as an
underworld broker and arms
dealer would have earned him a higher
bounty. He might just be able to call
in a favor with the Celestial Dragons to
keep it nice and low if he wants, though.
At 350 million there are two more
Supernovas: First is Capone Bege,
the #1 dad in all of One Piece (which isn’t
really that high of a bar to cross) and second
is Scratchmen Apoo, who really ought to
see a dentist about those piano teeth.
The fact that we’re just now getting to
our first non-Chopper Straw Hat really
shows just how infamous our crew has
become now that Luffy has officially
become a Yonkou. Cat Burglar Nami has
a bounty of 366 million, and I’m sure
she’s glad she’s on the relatively lower end
of the spectrum compared to her crewmates.
Pedro - RIP - had a bounty of 382,000,000
before his death on whole Cake Island.
Up next we have two more Straw Hats: Soul
King Brook has a bounty of 383 million and
Cyborg Franky has a bounty of 394 million.
Fitting for two of the crewmates who went
up against the terrifying Big Mom. I mean,
what other pirate can say they motorcycled
Big Mom in the face? And Brook managed to
do the impossible: he spent a night in Big
Mom’s bed and actually survived. Even
though he’s already dead. Yohohohoho.
Sharing a bounty of 400 million are the
hard-headed Ulti from Kaidou’s crew and Karasu,
Revolutionary Army commander and
wielder of the Soot Soot fruit.
400 million was also the bounty
that Luffy earned after leading
an unprecedented prison break out of Impel
Down and participating in the Marineford War.
Big Mom’s egg-y subordinate, Baron
Tamago, has a bounty of 429 million.
Another Revolutionary Army Commander,
Belo Betty, is worth 457 million - fitting
for someone with the perfect fruit for
inciting riots against the government.
Sasaki of Kaidou’s Flying
Six has a bounty of 472 mil.
And another member of the Flying Six,
Black Maria, is worth 480 million,
an amount she shares with the former warlord
and alleged son of Whitebeard, Edward Weevil.
The sniper king himself, God Usopp, is our first
pirate to cross the half billion threshold with
500 million. This is kind of insane because that
means that one Usopp is worth one million Bepos.
Of course, this is also the number that
Luffy earned after the Straw Hats dethroned
Doflamingo and freed the island of
Dressrosa from the corrupt warlord.
Izo, one of the 9 red scabbards and former member
of the Whitebeard Pirates was worth 510
million before their death on Onigashima.
Don Chinjao, former enemy of
Garp and current ally of Luffy,
is worth 542 million, which just goes to show:
the pointier the head, the higher the bounty.
Who’s Who, Kaidou’s subordinate who
was formerly a member of the CP9
has a bounty of 546 mil. As the
person who was held responsible
Little Oars Jr - a descendant of the ancient
giant Oars - has a bounty of 550 million - a
bounty he shared with his friend Portgas D.
Ace. As a division commander of the Whitebeard
Pirates and the son of Gol D. Roger himself,
Ace definitely earned his massive bounty.
Charlotte Snack is one of Big Mom’s children
we still haven’t met. He was one of her Sweet
Commanders before he was defeated by the Mad Monk
Urouge off-screen prior to the Whole Cake Island
arc. One thing we *do* know about Snack,
though, is that his bounty is 600,000,000.
Just a bit higher at 602 million is the
Revolutionary Army’s Chief of Staff:
The Flame Emperor Sabo. As the 2nd in command for
the biggest thorn in the world government’s side,
it’s no surprise that this bounty is
higher. We do suspect an increase soon,
though, considering that Sabo learned the
government’s greatest secret during the Reverie.
Charlotte Perospero, Big Mom’s eldest son,
reaches a bounty of 700,000,000 - higher
than one of the Sweet Commanders even
though he doesn’t hold the title himself.
However, he’s not as high as our next
Big Mom child: Charlotte Cracker,
who gave even Gear 4th Luffy a tough battle
on Whole Cake and has a bounty of 860 million.
Taking a short break from the Charlottes, though,
we have the Devil Child herself: Nico Robin,
who has a bounty of 930 million. Being one of
the only people in the world who can read the
poneglyphs, Robin is one of the most dangerous
individuals for the World Government. Therefore,
she earns a bounty just as high as many characters
who are physically much stronger than her.
Slightly higher than Robin, though, is yet another
Sweet Commander - Charlotte
Smoothie with 932 million.
But next comes our first billion berry
bounty: before meeting this character,
we could hardly conceive of a bounty so high
- we’d never seen anything like it in the
series. With a 1,000,000,000 berry bounty is
one of Kaidou’s All-Stars, Jack the Drought.
Black Leg Sanji is our first Straw Hat to break
a billion, being worth 1, 032,000,000. However,
an earlier bounty of Sanji’s is definitely
interesting to look at. His bounty poster
after Dressrosa which was worth 177 million
is the only poster in the series we’ve seen
that says “Only Alive” instead of “Dead or Alive.”
This was due to the interference of the Vinsmoke
Family whose Germa Kingdom is a member nation of
the World Government. Vinsmoke Judge wanted to
keep his long lost son alive as a political pawn
to marry into the Charlotte Family. That didn’t
work out too well for him. On his next bounty,
Sanji returned to being wanted Dead or Alive.
But above him is the first billion berry
man that Luffy went head to head with.
The future-sight master and strongest of
Big Mom’s children, Charlotte Katakuri,
with 1,057,000,000. Fun Fact: Since Luffy
is heavily associated with the number 56,
which can be read as Go-Mu in Japanese, Katakuri’s
bounty having a 57 million in it was Oda’s way
of hinting at the Mochi User’s superiority
to Luffy at the beginning of their fight.
The Knight of the Sea, Jinbe, has a bounty
of 1,100,000,000 now that he’s one of the
most powerful commanders of the Straw Hat
Grand Fleet. Add his former status as a
Shichibukai and leader of the Sun
Pirates and you get someone with a
resumé so crazy that he’s surpassed Sanji
for the third highest bounty in the crew.
And just above him at 1,111,000,000
is Roronoa Zoro who handily deserves
a billion plus bounty after taking
out Kaidou’s 2nd in command. Hmmm,
maybe all of those ones are supposed to be
hinting at something - like how he’s Luffy’s
*unofficial* first mate? Maybe someday
he’ll finally earn that title for real.
Queen the Plague has a bounty of 1,320,000,000.
It’s higher than even Sanji and Zoro’s bounties,
but you have to remember that bounties aren’t
just power levels. They also have to do with
a pirates’ threat level both to the government
itself and society as a whole. But while no one’s
getting food poisoning from Sanji’s expertly
crafted plates, Queen does have a habit of
releasing terrible diseases of his own design
onto victims, hence his nickname “The Plague.”
Marco the Phoenix comes in at 1,374,000,000
- the former second in command of the
Whitebeard Pirates is powerful
enough to take on King and Queen
at the same time. And I have a feeling that
the World Government wouldn’t look too kindly
upon the new leader of the Whitebeard
Pirates after the Marineford War pretty
much demolished the Marine Headquarters. This
is all the perfect recipe for a massive bounty.
However, it’s not quite as massive as King the
Wildfire, who has a 1,390,000,000 berry bounty. As
the last known Lunarian and a prized government
test subject who escaped from Punk Hazard,
the World Government has every reason to
want to get King back. And this motivation
gets even higher when you think about how much
King seems to know about the legend of Joyboy.
After Whole Cake Island, where Luffy
stormed a Yonkou’s territory to free Sanji,
he earned a new bounty of 1,500,000,000 after
being named the 5th Emperor of the
sea, his sixth bounty in the series.
Boa Hancock, the Pirate Empress of Amazon Lily
and former warlord of the sea has a new bounty
of 1,659,000,000. After the warlord system was
abolished, she was one of the former Shichibukai
who achieved a huge bounty. With her dangerous
devil fruit capable of turning anyone to stone and
a country’s worth of haki-using warriors at her
disposal, she’s truly a force to be reckoned with.
Sir Crocodile is the first warlord the
Straw Hats ever fought and he was their
first true test of strength in the Grand
Line. Now that he’s a leader of the Cross
Guild and actively issuing bounties on
high-profile marines, he’s surged to the
top of the government’s most wanted list
with a bounty of 1,965,000,000 berries.
And for the next place on our list, there’s a
three way tie. For toppling the former yonkou
Kaidou and Big Mom, the alliance of Monkey D.
Luffy, Eustass Kid, and Trafalgar Law have all
earned massive bounties of 3 billion berries.
This just shows how seriously the government are
taking the worst generation now that they’ve made
a real name for themselves in the New World. This
is Luffy’s current bounty, but I’ve got a feeling
it’ll go even higher before the end of the series,
which is insane because it’s a whole 100 times
higher than his original bounty of 30,000,000.
But even above these three is the fearsome, the
almighty, Buggy the Clown. His bounty is now
a staggering 3,189,000,000 - fitting for one of
the four emperors and a prime candidate for the
pirate that will claim the One Piece and become
the pirate king. After failing upwards all the
way from the East Blue, this former cabin boy for
Roger has ascended to the top of the pirate world.
Of course, Dracule Mihawk keeps him in check
- or at least tries to. This is the true
powerhouse of the Cross Guild and the World’s
Greatest Swordsman. According to Crocodile,
he was known as a marine hunter before he
was named a Shichibukai. But now that the
warlord system has been dissolved,
his bounty is now 3,590,000,000.
Marshall D. Teach AKA Blackbeard has
a bounty of 3,996,000,000 berries. He
started his pirate career on Whitebeard’s
crew, achieved the status of Shichibukai,
and broke some of the most terrifying prisoners
out of Impel Down to join his crew. This would
already be worth a huge bounty, but then you
add the fact that he’s the only person ever
known to consume two devil fruits and they’re
two of the most destructive and powerful ones
in the entire world. After he conquered
the remains of Whitebeard’s territory,
he established himself as an emperor of
the sea with a massive bounty to match.
Before the end of the list with some
unbelievably high bounties, though,
it’s time for some honorable mentions: There
are some characters with unknown bounties
that we’re sure would be among the highest
that have yet to be revealed. For instance,
what was Rocks D. Xebec’s bounty? We also don’t
know many members of the Blackbeard, Red Hair,
or Roger Pirates’ bounties. And we assume the
highest bounty belongs to the “world’s most wanted
man” and Luffy’s father, Monkey D. Dragon. But
until we find out for sure, we can only speculate
how crazy high these bounties were. Now it’s
time for the top 5 highest bounties in One Piece.
In 5th place is the mysterious Red-Haired Shanks,
worth 4,048,900,000. Why such a huge bounty? Well,
let’s look at what we do know about this
enigmatic figure: He served on Roger’s crew,
and he stole the Sun God Nika fruit from the
World Government and gave it to Luffy. Moreover,
though, he’s almost certainly connected to
the Figarland Family of the Celestial Dragons,
having been found by Roger
as an infant on God Valley.
Add his insane conqueror’s haki feat
and he’s easily worth over 4 billion.
And the other original four emperors also
possess bounties above 4 billion. Charlotte
Lin Lin, otherwise known as Big Mom, was worth
4,388,000,000 berries before her defeat on
Onigashima. As a former Rocks Pirate member and
one of the emperors of the sea, she cemented
her status as one of the strongest pirates in the
world. Her Soul-Soul fruit is insanely versatile,
her durability is incredible, and
her taste for sweets unparalleled.
Her former Rocks Crew Mate Kaidou
was known as the world’s strongest
creature. As a young pirate, he broke
free from government experimentation
at Punk Hazard. After partnering with
Orochi and conquering the land of Wano,
he became a warlord and was one of
the biggest arms dealers in the world,
even having the government itself as a client.
All of this earned him a bounty of 4,611,100,000
And yet another Rocks Crew member and the
strongest man in the world was Edward Newgate,
better known as Whitebeard.
This user of the quake-quake
fruit who was even able to wage war
against the full forces of the World
Government even while terminally
ill had a bounty of 5,046,000,000.
But even he can’t compete with the highest known
bounty in all of One Piece. With a bounty of
5,564,800,000 is the king of the pirates
himself, the man who found Laugh Tale and
started the golden age of piracy: Gol
D. Roger. To put that in perspective,
that’s about 38.5 million US dollars and around
35 million Euro. It’s too late to collect on it,
but just imagine what you could
do with that chunk of change.
These bounties are insanely high, but if
you want to see how crazy the Straw Hats’
bounties will be at the end of the series,
then you should check out this video!